okay yesterday we went through the
content of Donald Trump's speech
declaring a national emergency to try to
get the border wall built and when we
talked about this yesterday I mentioned
to you that right after his Rose Garden
speech declaring this emergency and
talking about how this is all so
important and it's all got to be done
Donald Trump immediately went down to
one of his golf clubs and was spotted at
the omelet station and apparently I'm
not pronouncing omelet correctly and
we'll deal with that later on in the
show and he's pictured grabbing an
omelet before or after his golfing and
of course when you say I'm having an
emergency that's not usually followed by
I need a ham and cheese omelet and three
diet cokes immediately it's usually
followed by something related to the
emergency that you have declared right
the us-mexico border emergency which
requires commandeering funds
circumventing the will of Congress it's
even worse than we thought because now
we have found out that Donald Trump not
only golfed right after declaring the
national emergency he golfed three days
in a row three days in a row of a
national emergency so important that it
requires as far as Trump is concerned
circumventing the decisions made by the
US House and Senate and he couples them
with three days of golfing Saturday
reportedly included six hours of golf
interesting detail Trump has been
showing up to start golfing around 9:00
a.m. each of these three days Trump
doesn't even show up to the Oval Office
in the same building where he lives
until the level at 11:00 a.m. on a
normal day he has now made depending on
which numbers you look at between a
hundred and fifty nine and a hundred and
seventy two visits to golf clubs during
his presidency this is more vacation
than most people take in multiple years
who were not the President of the United
States and of course Trump has also made
money by making these golf trips to his
golf clubs one example is that over the
weekend a Chinese delegation met with
Trump not at the White House but at his
Mara
Lago Resort Trump is playing golf and
making money personally while a national
emergency
supposedly warrants getting around
Congress to commandeer money from the
military and the Department of Defense I
as I was reading about this it reminded
me of this infamous George W Bush moment
where he delivered an impactful
statement about terror right before
teeing off on the golf course we must
stop the terror I call upon all nations
to do everything they can to stop these
terrorist killers thank you now watch
this Drive there you go
I don't actually think Trump believes
this is really an emergency Pat I'm
curious what you think
I believe Trump believes three million
Hillary voters voted illegally in 2016 I
believe that because he's privately
continued to say it even after the
conversation was out of the media I
think Trump probably believes in real
life that the Russia probe is a witch
hunt I don't believe Trump actually
thinks there is a border crisis that
warrants a national emergency he even
said during the Rose Garden speech I
didn't have to do this I did this
because I feel like building the wall
more quickly
I believe Pat that Trump knows deep down
this one is not real yeah I think he
just wants to rally and satisfy his face
of supporters and this vacation time to
me it sounds like he sees himself as
having completed the job like he worked
so hard to try to get wall funding
during the government shutdown to buckle
and then that three week period when we
didn't know if the government was going
to be shut down again that now he
deserves a vacation because he did what
he had to do he declared the national
emergency and now we're moving on he can
take a break whatever Trump thinks we've
got to hope that the courts are going to
stop this absolutely ridiculous power
grab and misuse of the national
emergency declaration either way under
the best-case scenario for the wall
builders not much of this wall is ever
going to be built
even if Donald Trump has six more years
as president eight billion dollars
would in the best-case-scenario build
some tiny piece of the wall it would
take years lawsuits will slow it down
and the next Democratic president will
simply be able to end it so this could
change but unless something radically
changes even on the basis of this
declaration almost no wall is actually
going to be built and then that
transforms this from an actual
discussion about immigration policy and
what can be done pragmatically to just
political posturing about who can claim
victory on the wall as Pat pointed out
earlier and what that means is that
every American loses we all lose when
these become merely political footballs
that are thrown back and forth make sure
to follow me on instagram i'm on
instagram at david pakman also on the
david pakman show Instagram page we have
a very funny photo collage I I'm
actually calling it a photo essay from
producer Pat of producer max having
string cheese at David Patrick David
Pakman show studios and it was Max's
birthday earlier this week and to
celebrate Max's birthday on the at David
Pakman show Instagram account there's a
photo essay by producer Pat which I am
just calling Pat string cheese 2019 is
how I would like to describe it and
shout out the producer max I would say
that he is on the Mount Rushmore of
current David Pakman show producers yes
and he's the only person on that
proverbial Mount Rushmore interestingly
enough all right let's take a break we
are going to talk next about FOMO the
fear of missing out and it's gonna be a
really great interview coming up in mere
minutes after this quick break one of
today's sponsors pres aback is offering
you some free stuff that I want to tell
you about suppressor box is based in New
York City they help keep guys wardrobes
fresh without breaking the bank because
when you become a member of spresso box
each month you'll get a new box sent to
your door filled with five or six
stylish hand-picked accessories and
pieces of clothing for men it includes
high end socks neckties really nice
sunglasses wallets watches bracelets
high-quality pens and hair combs
the classy stuff that makes it easy to
put a little more pop into your wardrobe
without having to spend a ton of money a
subscription is just 25 bucks a month
but your new box every single month is
guaranteed to have items with a combined
value of over $100 a couple of the
things I got are a really nice money
clip a pocket square and some great
socks go check out the different things
that they put in their monthly boxes
they have a lot of really nice-looking
stuff everyone in our audience can get
one month totally free when you click
the link underneath this video and use
the promo code Pakman that's PA que ma N